she also i'm gonna effing kill you as
the cop attempts to de-escalate like
she's shouting that she's gonna stab
somebody what was he supposed to do
get out of the van and ask michael
bryan's about the trouble she's
experiencing in her life or you know
stop her from stabbing the other girl in
the neck
all of this is ridiculous on its face
now the way that we know this is
ridiculous on its face is because not
only do we have the original body cam
angle on the mickey and ryan shooting
in which you can see clearly makia
bryant charging at this other girl
who's pinned against a car and raising a
butcher knife to sh
to stab her we now have another angle on
the makita brian shooting
this angle shows that makia bryant
is is lunging at another woman with a
knife
and people are shouting about it people
are
here here's the video
okay she's shouting that she's gonna
stab somebody
she she also i'm gonna effing kill you
as the cop attempts to de-escalate like
what is there is there possibly better
evidence that the cop did the right
thing here
okay but according to the media remember
the cop can do the right thing and it
doesn't matter because
every bad thing in america that happens
if it happens to a black person
is an element of systemic racism right
everything is attributable to the system
because the goal here is not to make
life better for people
the goal here is to tear down the
systems the same systems by the way
that have provided for more freedom and
more security
in the past half century than black
people have anywhere else
on planet earth america is an incredible
place for black people to live
it is better than virtually all other
places on planet earth
by polling data america is one of the
least racist countries on earth
black household income is higher in the
united states than it is anywhere else
on planet earth
this notion that america is some sort of
hellscape for black americans compared
with other countries on earth
is completely evidence-free but that is
the proposal that all of america's
institutions are terrible and that every
bad thing that happens to a black person
or for which a black person is
responsible is attributable generally
to the system at large as i talked about
a little bit earlier this week this is
the soft bigotry of low expectations
it's not it's just the
hard bigotry of no expectations in a
free country
where the law applies black people
apparently have no agency at all and are
not to be held responsible for their
actions in any way
which is why you end up with articles in
the washington post talking about she
didn't even have a chance to live her
life
this is all about the system
makia bryant beams at her mother in a
tick-tock clip then throws her arms
around her neck
as beyonce's dance for you plays in the
background the team lip syncs the lyrics
i'ma take this time to show you how much
you mean to me because you are all i
need
it's an intimate moment between mother
and daughter who are working hard to
reunite after bryant was placed in
foster care family member said
they had a close bond said don bryant a
cousin of makia's mother mckee was just
an all-around good person
on tuesday 16 year old bryant was
fatally shot by a columbus police
officer responding to a call for help
at her foster home in the city southeast
body camera footage released by police
shows brian swinging what appears to be
a knife at two people during an
altercation outside the property before
an officer arrives and fires four shots
at her torso
on thursday family members struggle to
make sense of the killing at least the
third fatal shooting by columbus police
this year
okay but how many of those were
justified do we have the details on any
of those because this one was it was a
justified shoot
don bryant said he had a hard time
recognizing the teen seen in the police
video lunging at others
he doesn't condone any violence but
called the officer's decision to open
fire disproportionate
there are other disengagement techniques
police could have used here
said bryant who has served on the
mansfield ohio city council i'm a
supporter of police's former city
councilor
i understood their moves their tactics
what they do i just don't understand
what happened here you don't understand
what happened here i mean it seems
pretty clear what happened here since
it's you know on tape from several
different angles
the the entire media coverage here
is angled toward ignoring the actual
circumstances of the case
officials identified the officer who
fired the shots as nicolas reardon and
said he had been taken off street duty
while the investigation proceeds
reardon 23 appears to be the son of a
retired columbus police sergeant named
ted riordan an air force veteran and
long time
basic training instructor instructor at
the department's training academy
when ted reardon retired last year the
department posted a tribute video
nicholas ridden was a high school
wrestler at columbus's bishop waterson
high school
the wrestling team's twitter feed showed
him posing with his dad as a senior in
2016. he joined the columbus pd in
december 2019.
the shooting immediately ignited debate
about whether deadly force was warranted
okay well that debate ignited because
the biden administration jumped on this
to suggest that the shooting was wrong
and again
emblematic of of white systemic racism
but i'll tell you what it really was
emblematic of more than anything else
how many of these cases are parents
really deeply involved
with the people who end up shot by the
police seriously
are we allowed to ask that question
because we have on tape mckia bryan's
mother
giving tearful interviews but makia
bryant was in a foster home
when she attacked another girl with a
knife where was michael bryan's mother
then
here's mickey o'brien's mother on cnn my
heart is really broken right now because
i miss my baby to be honest i miss
already
and it's really hard
for me i haven't eaten
and i can't eat because i miss my
baby i had a beautiful baby
she was taken from me okay your health
your heart goes out for the mother at
the same time where was mom
makia bryant was in a foster home where
was mom adam toledo was shot in chicago
again a justified shooting it was
treated by the media as an unjustified
shooting the adam toledo shooting
where were adam toledo's parents adam
toledo had been missing for two nights
he's a 13 year old boy on the streets he
had joined the latin kings which is a
gang in chicago
he just got a tattoo to that effect and
he was shooting weaponry at cars
where were his parents you want to talk
about alleviating problems why don't we
start
with some of the roots of the problems
rather than blaming the people who are
charged with basically putting a
band-aid on criminality by attempting to
stop the criminals
but again you can't talk about that
because if you talk about that then it
devolves to personal responsibility
and the left has suggested black people
have no agency in america it is the hard
bigotry of no expectations
if there is a bad situation then we're
just supposed to expect that there will
be widespread riots
if there is a if there is a black girl
who
tries to stab another black girl with a
knife she has no responsibility for
those actions
nor do we care only if the cop shows up
to stop it do we care because that's
emblematic of systemic racism
this is what ibrahim kennedy says zebra
mkhindi who is just a grifter and a race
baiter and
a person with terrible awful horrible
ideas he's a tyrant
here he is on cnn with brianna keeler
talking about how the cops should never
have done this
when i look at that video i asked myself
if if that would have been a 16 year old
white girl in a wealthy suburban
neighborhood
would the police officer have sought
to disarm this girl would the police
officers
sought to talk her down would the police
officer you
would have used legal lethal force and
it's hard for me to believe
that that would have happened it's hard
to me to to believe that that
officer would not have responded
differently
for a different girl in a different
community everyone kenny says a few
things there
one he suggests that if the police
officers showed up they would try to
talk down
a white girl who's doing this to another
white girl in an upper income
neighborhood
okay now notice how he adds an upper
income neighborhood this wasn't an upper
income neighborhood right this is a
pretty obviously lower income
neighborhood the income
the class gap does matter here a little
bit which i'll explain in a second but
the notion that a police officer even
would have had time to talk to makia
bryant belies the facts
there's a grand total between the time
the officer the officer arrives he steps
out of his car he says what's going on
between that time and the shoot is nine
seconds
nine seconds you think that not what was
supposed to do
get out of the van and ask mikey brian
about the trouble she's experiencing in
her life or you know stop her from
stabbing the other girl in the neck
under all circumstances if a cop shows
up and somebody is wielding a knife and
another person about to stab them the
cop will shoot them
you think the cop went through the cop
said well i mean she's black gotta take
her down
no evidence to that effect at all so
abram kennedy is just a liar and he is
slandering that police officer as a
racist
and so that is number one number two the
broader question
that ibrahim kendi is asking is wrong
the question is not would a police
officer have shot an upper income white
person doing this to another upper
income white person the answer is pretty
obviously yes again because you have a
nine second gap
in which to make the decision to stop
somebody trying to stab the other person
the real question is
in what neighborhoods are these crimes
tending to take place
and what sort of cultural decisions have
to be made to stop those crimes from
taking place
in the first place because the
underlying lie that is being told is
that everyone is equally likely to try
to stab each other with a knife and this
is untrue
this is how you come up with the idiocy
from the left that if the police
officers shoot a disproportionate number
of black suspects
this is because the police are racist as
opposed to looking at the underlying
levels of criminal activity
that doesn't mean that race has anything
to do
with your criminal level of activity it
does mean that crime is not equally
distributed
per capita among the races white people
commit more crimes than asian people per
capita
hispanic people commit more crimes than
asian people than white people and asian
people per capita and black folks commit
more violent crimes per capita than
hispanic folks and white folks and asian
folks
okay those are just basic stats that's
not racist and that has nothing to say
about race as the causative factor
because race isn't the causative factor
but because everyone think abram kennedy
thinks that race is always the causative
factor
he believes that no matter what other
explanatory causal factors are there
ranging from single motherhood to
poverty to ingrained generations
of of deep-seated racism going back
several generations right this is the
case that thomas soul makes he says
there are higher levels
of violent crime in the black community
because there's sort of
embedded codes of honor from the
american south there and
a systemic lack of policing for decades
that led to
higher rates of crime in the black
community over the course of a century
him instead of going there he just goes
to it must be that the white police
officer is a racist and it's
his implicit bias and if this had been a
white person he wouldn't have shot them
that is shallow it's ridiculous and of
course it is racist because it says that
all white police officers are implicitly
biased and any police officer who shoots
a black suspect about to kill somebody
is in fact a racist the battle for the
culture is heating up
we here at the daily wire are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe
ring that bell because you're not going
to want to miss a single moment